and we're celebrating the launch of walk
jogs 2 today with a live stream brought
to you well brought to us by our friends
at pizza hut this is delivered by pizza
hut we have some special guests also
jovenshire and lasercorn are here thank
you guys for joining us so the problem
we're going to play some dogs too and
dig into some pizza hut triple treat
boxes both of those things sound good
but before we do that we just want to
talk about this giveaway that you can
get we have this super sweet xbox
controller that comes with a ps
that comes with an xbox one s and you
can win this every hour until december
24th by logging in
to
pizzahut.com
xbox one with the code that you find
inside the front flap of your triple
treat box so for the holiday season
pizza hut partner with xbox to give away
a newly released xbox one s console and
this custom pizza hut controller every
hour so you could totally win this you
guys should probably try this too
so yeah what we're gonna do i know i saw
that on the desktop and i'm like i want
this one thank you so what we're gonna
do is we're going to order on the pizza
hut app right now oh cause i'm longbeard
yeah i'm so hot are you guys hungry
starving i'm sorry i didn't mean to get
so aggressive i had a banana for
breakfast it was a poor choice i should
have had something
lucky for you we have the triple treat
box nice so on the pizza hut app here
i'm going to place an order so each of
you gets to pick a topping pepperoni i
call pepperoni wow all right he called
dibs on pepperoni i i need
you know i'm feeling very um meat eatery
i want some sausage actually sausage all
right so the triple juice box comes with
three treats we've got one medium pizza
with one topping another medium pizza
within one topping and then we get a
hershey's cookie
so you've got that to look forward to so
we'll replace my order and make sure
that it went through and we're going to
jump into some watchdogs too so
i've placed my order
and let's see how many missions that we
can get done
before our pizza room what do
i've been dancing since we had the uh
the music playing before the live stream
actually let's check out the game um
so there's a lot more wait keep dancing
we just went live
okay in that case back to the dancing
back to the dancing get down you make
him dab can i uh let me see let me see
if i can
um
don't walk away from me stay no no
almost
no no
no not a damn that's not you
do the race suspicion everyone
best dance move ever yeah that was yeah
oh yeah i'm so excited to be here on
youtube live streaming
all right um my favorite thing to do in
this game is actually uh dang it wrong
button uh i'm actually not gonna tell
you what i like to do i'm just gonna
show you
because it's the greatest well hang on
what okay yeah you could show okay go
ahead find me a bus
oh wait that'll do that'll do that'll do
come back here come back here come back
why are you chasing it you're a hacker i
know hacking no okay go backwards go
backwards no don't why are you still
dancing
all right i thought i could dance it to
stop also everyone on the live stream
right now talk to us on twitch and
youtube we are looking at chat right now
so get your questions in for jovenshire
and lasercorn oh yeah tell us what kind
of pizza toppings you guys like were we
wrong oh here we go we were not there's
some debate we picked the best one yes
there's some debate as to whether
hawaiian is acceptable or not
and uh it's we're a couch divided yes
i love hawaiian pizza oh i'm the only
one on my side i was gonna say joey
joven likes hawaiian pizza too i don't
believe fruit belongs on pizza but like
have you ever had watermelon pizza no
you know because fruit i would try it
though
must remain separate i love pineapple i
love watermelon i love pizza i just
don't put those things together
oh no i'm out of i'm out of
juice sorry i'm i'm all about your
debate
you almost went yeah banned a van
i was thinking we could uh we could do
some car surfing and have chassis to
judge who does better who's the best i
am ready to judge who does this i think
you're out of bot juice you're out of
boxes
i had to hold the button i've got that
bot
um let me find some people to hack and
we will
do that again um oh man
if i can add one thing to this game it
would be unlimited
oh what happened to this i'm sure there
will be cheat codes is that your fault i
don't know
this guy
so what is the goal of this mission just
to get down what well the goal of our
mission was to carcer but joven spent
all
i'm stealing some botnet from this guy
oh jeez
he's like i've got butt down yeah so
this guy has money
but we've already stolen from him this
guy has what nothing nothing he's what a
loser he is nothing to us all right this
guy's got botnet so we've refilled our
botnet [ __ ] that was fast
we hacked all the money we did so good
job we haven't had money in botnet not
quite the same things but yeah but we
we're going to spend it in all the
different ways now you're going to judge
me first i'm going to i'm going to car
surf this car and you're going to tell
me how i do versus how it does all right
all right
full speed ahead
left right
oh look at me dodging no i dodged it
dogs right into a tree all right that
was a three at the end did you hack into
a dodge minivan
no but i did ram into that tree
oh well played
you want to try again or is it
based on that performance yeah no you
have to judge me based on that
performance don't judge me too hard
joven's up next i'm over here
i'm trying to get you some botnet i
appreciate that see if i can get some
friendly competition he's giving me all
the botnet that i'm gonna need for my
sweet sweet moves
over on youtube we've got some votes for
pepperoni two votes three votes for
pepperoni being the best just cheese
from fallout kid i like chocolate
bunnies from deshawn i love peppers
pizza though on my pizza
nothing wrong with a little peanut
butter and anchovies
neo caleb peanut butter and anchovies
ban that person from the chocolate
half of that is good um peanut which oh
anchovies no no no no peanut butter i
think you put peanut butter on pizza
peanut butter on some pizzas is a great
idea a sweet i've never done peanut
butter on pizza is it something i should
try uh i i do recommend it all right
full bot uh i know i saw the vehicle
that i need for my next uh performance
it's uh i'm literally dubbing it a
performance because it it's gonna be
that it will be a performance remember
chastity is judging you i am judging
you you're so beautiful today i was
watching uh you
you dropped some news all the
information you do i dropped that news
thank you thank you so much don't let
that be that you're just trying to get
me to vote for you
yeah
you're clearly buttering her up
can i get in here oh yeah i can't okay
oh you're gonna go right through the
glass do it no no yeah aim at that no no
get on that other one and then charge
forward through come on guys
car surf through the glass
wait first get rid of that other car
ride it back that one up back that one
yeah uh way up okay you're in the way
get out how did that magically happen
and all of a sudden
do it
through the course
yeah
i'm sorry he's already winning he did
everything
all right
that was pretty good
uh he joking one i'm sorry yeah yeah
admittedly
look if i hadn't known there was a place
i could do it through glass
it's all about presentation yeah it's
okay you have the better starting point
oh oh oh oh here let me in here let me
in here uh did it steal the truck are
you just ghost riding this truck i'm
ghost riding this truck all right
can you hack all the i can't ask
anything yeah
anything
that's great about it i'm out of pockets
oh bad idea what's the best thing you
can hack in this game uh
cranes forklifts yeah i like the lift so
there's this kind of uh it's like a
scissor lift lift it goes up and down
and i like to hunt people with it
it's the climax 5000. oh no one escapes
the climax
because you can read their names and
stuff so i pretend i'm a serial killer
uh
see i i would love to fly joe but now
that you've defeated me do you want to
try and do a mission or do you want to
we can do a mission do you want to set
us up for uh yeah what kind of mission
should be for um well we've still got
time to fight triple tree box around
that's not meant to do that oh no i have
bad news i believe i stole that um that
motorcycle and
uh the police got mad at me so we might
have said oh yes yeah we have some
troubles um but i'm gonna just blend
into society by getting on the bus yeah
no no i'm i'm driving the bus oh you're
you're the bus i'm the bus driver
get out here anyone that needs to stop
this is the metropolitan area who wants
to ride on your bus oh okay
it seems a little unsafe nothing to see
here oh my gosh uh the cops the cops are
on you i know this is pack their cars
make them tired
get rid of them
yeah um i think that worked a little bit
and i haven't gotten
to go i'm gonna make an innocent youtube
a completely
legal
u-turn that wasn't even a youtuber it's
a four-point turn it's like an e-turn or
something i've never even heard of the
type of
proper direction now all right see this
guy
you're in my left
okay i've actually hacked him into your
way yeah
all right
did i do it did i do it nope oh you
created a proximity
charge there okay now this guy this guy
you're going to go
this way well the steam fight do it
it's very
uh inconspicuous uh one might say my
activities are innocuous in fact if
anything you gave them a landmark it's
like the guy in the bus by the giant
steam explosion i gotta cut them down i
gotta get into another find another bus
and then drive with that bus and they
won't know what what is your obsession
with buses why do you need another bus
yeah
because it's so incredible like there's
innocuous
no one ever suspects the
speeding bus you know what to knock you
i do know it's peaceful oh see he's gone
he's going that way he's gotta go uh
home to feed his dogs whatever
that's true um and this guy just he all
of a sudden realized that he left his
other mom at home
okay um i'm just a peaceful bus driver
oh wow guys that guy really hates you
he's trying to get under your butt can't
get under the bus let me see
that's a tunnel all right go down there
maybe you can lose
i'm good to go oh there's a guy in front
of me yeah you turn
okay uh your bus is on fire i mean uh
yeah we have to be the oh man yeah uh
you're dead i just passed that
controller pass that controller
you fell asleep fell asleep at the wheel
um you know you might you may jest sir
but i believe the chat is saying how
great that uh that runway let's let's
check in with the chad see how they
think he did yeah let's see um the chat
is saying
they're just laughing a lot thank you
there we go that's not an indication
that you did well oh man i'm here to
entertain what's up gamespot audience
i'm the joker i'm here to entertain
lasercorn's up next and he's very
entertaining
when you fail all right do you want me
to actually do a mission or do you want
me to yeah let's do a mission
let's see what kind of mission we can
pull off before our triple treat bucks
gets here yeah let's oh man yeah
let's see i'll let you guys decide we
got the dead sec app here we are on
twitch and youtube to help us decide
which mission we should take so we got
side operation
uh it says the opd has a stress relation
with the oakland communities interesting
uh
okay or we've got acquire a new e-cart
battery
can maybe go go-karting wait really
that's a thing go-karting maybe well
e-carding okay i think which i think is
like go-karting just you know
electronically gather followers to take
down bloom
or
meet wrench in a cafe meat restaurant uh
nothing meat ranch
that is an interesting nickname for him
to go with what do you guys want to do
the ink cart i want to know if you want
to get you want to get this cart battery
let us know on twitch or youtube which
one you want to do but be sure to hack
his phone first we're going to meet
wrench you want me to hack him i just
stole his van i feel like hacking him is
mean yeah but if he calls the police
you're screwed see someone's calling the
police do you see that little is he
chasing him no that orange triangle
there he has money okay but now behind
you directly behind okay that orange dot
is not the police no that is someone
calling the police
someone has seen a crime and they are
being aggressive
and they're saying uh this is a horrible
thing that just happened see this is
weird because i have a i have like a
flashing orange destination one way but
then my
blue path is
they're calling the police it's like a
waypoint or a marker
you can't see anything i i
can't
uh
if you if you don't know anything about
the jovenshire let me just tell you he's
very blind very blunt he doesn't know
what's going on um
so we're on this mission
if you guys are just turning tuning in
we are playing watch dogs too it's
launch day
and we're joined by lasercorn and
jovenshire and they're taking on some
missions while we wait for our pizza we
ordered some triple treat boxes from
pizza hut and those are coming those
come with two
pizzas and a big old cookie and we're
waiting for those it's going to be great
right and we also and breadsticks i
think come in my triple cheese bread
sticks oh my god you're pretty sure i'm
also getting breadsticks you are getting
breadsticks
let me help him off the ramp yeah oh oh
no wow i wanted to knock him over the
side i didn't know are those the cops
that were called on you no i what cops
what cops do you see
you are blind
there are no cops oh i need that purple
i'm hitting l1 on him it's not letting
me hack him joven number one okay well
what's going on persuade him off of his
car with maybe i can hack this car in
front of him and create a road block
can you do that wait or maybe i'm just
yeah let's do this we're gonna create a
roadblock and box
yeah the cops finally showed up an hour
after you said they were called no you
were just driving too fast and you're
super fast things are looking grim right
now
yeah i'm getting away i'm fast on this
motorcycle these cops have no idea what
they're dealing with can you uh
pack into some innocence
what why would i do that oh god that's a
cow
but i mean there's innocent cars here
you want me to just have it i need you
to hack into the police database and be
like oh guy purple motorcycle he's
innocent the police database oh oh hack
my way to innocence yeah i have no idea
how to do that
i actually don't know
what you can do i feel like maybe not
while driving motorcycles
i feel like the way they're sending me
is the wrong way um i would like to send
a message out to the people watching do
not hack and drive
do you want it is not safe uh we do not
condone it
there's got to be a shortcut here like
if i get all the people watching
let's check in with them so we have
people that are happy that we're gonna
go meet wrench um let's see
there's oh wait we're but we didn't do
that the rock and roll gamer said french
is my favorite character in this game
how about you guys what do you think
he's the one with the mask right yeah
the awesome mask has emote eyes
all right i just got to follow this blue
trail here we're actually not meeting
wrench because we did the ecard battery
because i thought that's what you want
to do that's what we could we could do
yeah let's do that next
okay battery we're almost there guys
almost there i believe
one of them also is almost there
is uh cops
but is our pizza almost here that's the
reason can we hack
somewhere in san francisco
all right
so the e-cart battery is in this place
oh i can hack the gates open open up
open says me maybe i could close the
gates keep the cops out all right
entering a restricted area oh might need
to get stealthy it's like a junkyard
this isn't shouldn't be restricted
i am stealthy i'm king of stealth look
how happy i am no one sees me
wait wait no nope oh okay people stop
instead of stealthier people see me in
our shoes
yeah climbing on the highest object
who's that up there if you see them oh
attack
is asking what makes this game amazing
what do you think guys uh one of the
first things that actually uh caught my
attention is the scale of the map it's
really giant you can go all over san
francisco all over oakland uh and right
off the bat it's just open world and
you'll actually find like
like landmarks uh when mari a friend of
ours was playing
she was able to like find like where she
went to school and like oh i used to
hang out in this corner because you know
she's shenanigans
yeah i i mean i like that it gives you a
lot of options and ways to complete
things like obviously i went about it
the wrong way there but you know you
could hack into different things and you
could create like proximity traps and
stuff like that and uh that's what i
like doing also i like uh
like i said taking over the uh the
scissors lifts and stuff like that
remote control rise of the machine stuff
is fun
what are you doing i have an idea to
sneak in but i need a van you're gonna
climb over the barboy or fence yes
that's not a bad idea but you could just
go walk right through the gate okay
no go ahead no do it your way because i
didn't succeed yeah he's good man he's
gonna get a van pull it up to the fence
and then climb on top of the back of it
oh that's not a bad idea that's a nice
back it up to the fence
i'm not stealing this car this person's
just driving crazy
all right whoops there you go here it is
where is my car going just go straight
that'd be horrifying if your car just
started
we got some traffic how did you beat me
incarcerated
we're also on twitch and youtube right
now if you have any questions for
lasercorn and jovanshire so let us know
what you want to see
but for those missions and tell us what
you think of watch dogs 2 or what you'd
like to see us do in the game
some sweet hacking there you go yeah
just get in sweet sweet hacking just get
in and pull it up there yeah okay you
weren't good enough to hack it there oh
there was time people my way jump
yeah your plan was bad yep bad plan did
not work actually you know no no it's
because i just gotta back the gate you
gotta be the back
see
i have actually you know driven trucks
to break into uh you know have you done
this before no this isn't your first
time
okay
this is a lot of hassle to to get a
go-kart back it is i think we could just
go to like the hardware store or
something
like here we can get it this must be
like a top secret
super go-kart battery
all right there we go and
question from the rock and roll gamer
can you guys think of any improvements
ubisoft should have made to this game uh
i haven't played the game enough to to
really know what improvements should be
made a laser card you've had some time
yeah it is really hard to kill people
with the forklift
if
if
i mean perhaps in a future patch or some
dlc if the forklift had turbo boost
it would be much easier to get in there
and uh you know spear people with those
those tongs and uh and push them into
the water and stuff so that's that's
probably the route i would go
i got you all right
guys
do something well i saw a guy you know
you could call gang hits on these guys
that's what i was looking to do
oh wait it's this guy right here go
ahead and call it
there you go perfect what's happening
right there wait no i think you called
the cops because it says forging heaven
why man oh he's straight because that
looks good
is he just a hater he just i think he
just it looked like he just slapped you
on the wow wow just go for no reason
yeah hater mode
all right just
oh yeah no you did do a gang hit so you
forged evidence that they were messing
with the game man i hope the gang takes
out that angry dude too all right just
get in here get in here are you sneaking
in i'm trying to whoa
you're entering a restricted area okay
now what you want to do is get to the
highest points make sure you can be seen
by everyone it's not actually a good
plan can i hack an attack dog
uh i don't believe so i don't believe
they are robotic attack dogs you could
be wrong it's bad
that's a cop oh boy
reinforcements have been called yes
you've been spotted in that case time to
make a run for it
where's that key at
it's uh to your left
the battery
yeah it's it's in there got it there you
go acquire it no no no no it has to go
in there oh wow awesome
where's what button is it
triangle
got it all right uh time to leave time
to wait quick real quick down on the
d-pad
why dance break oh dance break break
it's time for a dance break
yeah i got it boom
watch dog dance break watch times
time to watch time too
i think i got you followers for doing
that nice
and jump followers like a good dancer
jump yeah jump
jump
jump jump over it you're bad at this
just go through the gate it's barbed
wire he doesn't want to mess up his cool
pants
oh yeah
but if he snatches these are very
expensive pants if he snags his pants on
the barboy then it's all over it's all
over all over
okay let's see let's see if i can get
out of here safely no do you see all
those people right there
right oh man hack them okay it's just um
um you know
oh wait do i have a drone you're calling
in more people you do have a drone i
don't know how the drone would help you
in this scenario can i drop bombs
i think we're actually i don't know if
you have that upgrade but yes it can
drop explosives
all right i'm just going to you
know that one actually i don't can't
drop explosives but they can explode
though
what are my options at the bottom it
can't explode your options are jump
taunt oh you have taunt you could taunt
them and run it away how do i talk r2
i'm taunting okay now get out of there
draw their attention away this way oh
you're drawing them further in okay
question from chat would you say this
game is better than the first one yes
absolutely improvement all right the
first one
there you have it guys
do you see me come this way oh god wow
you they blew up your drone yeah they
were maybe there's another exit i'm
gonna see if i can find another way out
your drone's floated it there's no other
way just go through the gate look you
have weapons open your weapon wheel upon
the deep i understand i have weapons but
i'd like to get out of here uh oh emp
blast them that's a how about if i what
if i just shock him
you can shock him
nice and close here
yep you've been you're going to be
spotted careful yep yep yep that's how
okay i'm wrong i'm nervous time to run
time to run time oh jovenshire time to
run
let me out okay you've been killed all
right and you died now the only reason i
died last time let me just if i could
make an excuse for myself because i was
being chased by the cops and i didn't
have time to properly scout the
situation got it i will handle this
mission so you're well prepared you can
get this mission done yeah i can get
this mission done so we've yet to get
one mission completed but well we
completed the artificial carcinoma
we danced yeah we danced we
did the um the the car surfing yes
nailed that one uh-huh um i did collect
the e-card wait don't do we not have do
we have to go back in there yeah you
because you didn't finish the thing oh
wait actually do we already have it
does it auto save
uh let's let's check the map and see
where our
oh
yeah it looks like we we already have it
okay yeah i died on purpose it was just
like a fast way to get out of there yeah
totes on
uh how many uh uh
some roll call who's in the chat room
with us let's see who's in the chat room
we have some requests for some shout
outs yeah and also
who's better joven or laser car depends
on what you're trying to do
um at the game or in general yeah if you
want what do you want the answer see
something yeah that's gonna be laser
going yeah how edgy is this game asks
you know uh there is a dude with a mask
with a mode eyes on my eyes so that's
pretty edgy
that is pretty edgy uh we should fast
travel oh there's fast travel all right
oh you want to you want to get new
clothes i we they were asking how edgy
this game is
you're looking for edgier clothes yeah
too edgy
too edgy for you
too for me yeah
if you guys are just tuning in we're
playing watch dogs too it's launch day
it just came out today unless you're
playing on pc you have to wait till the
29th but you can play this on xbox one
and ps4 and also if you'd like to win an
xbox one to play this song you can get
an xbox one s from pizza hut and this
super sweet controller let me tell you
all about this giveaway so for the
holiday season pizza hut partnered with
xbox to give away a newly released xbox
one s console and a custom pizza
controller as you see here
every hour until december 24th you can
find the code on the inside front flap
of the triple treat box and enter at
pizzahut.com xbox one for a chance to
instantly win an xbox one s plus every
customer also instantly receives 10 off
an xbox game and one lucky customer will
also win the grand prize which includes
an xbox one s console a custom pizza hut
controller a samsung 4k su hd tv and an
audio system pretty sweet
so if you guys want to win i kind of
want to win one you have to order the
triple tree box which we did at the
beginning of this stream so hopefully we
can try to win our own controller and
what's in that triple treat box guys we
got two medium pizzas yep two medium one
topping pizzas that's right bread sticks
red sticks and a cookie and a giant
hershey's cookie hungry dude can you
hack them while you go that would be
sweet but i think that's considered
cheating i'm just kind of in mario kart
this is only cheating yeah you get
caught what yeah but i don't have my
hacking thing you can't cell phone and
drive right now
oh we can do it on a motorcycle but not
while we're eating
e-carding takes a hundred percent of
your focus job and i don't know if
you've ever eaten all of your kids
i can't catch up to them to do that
otherwise i totally would san francisco
is pretty perfect for this with what
it's hills and everything yeah if i
could do this in real life through the
yeah
oh is third good enough to win because
i don't know
almost
cut those corners come on i got the new
battery great shell man jovan died
getting this battery yeah there we go
over there yeah taking the first place
and i just gotta hang on to my lead
i can do this
come on drove and yeah
it better win a race not as violent as
you are i'm just scared of blue shells
cheer these guys on on twitch and
youtube
let us know what you think of this game
oh oh so how would you i think you're
actually doing it we're doing it i think
i just won joe is that the final lap
i'm the best at mario kart amazing
you are so good very nice uh question
for jovan do you like pizza from tory do
i like pizza i know i love pizza
it's just like the perfect combination
of all things that you want yeah you
could improve it right are you gonna
take the wheel now let me go see if i
can find you a velocity yes yes you're
gonna take the wheel can i still be
driving how much content is in this game
right now
quite a bit yeah i don't know i haven't
beaten it up alone there is a lot
um there's a lot of side missions of
course um because laser cord won we are
gonna go ahead and
uh we gotta get our victory dance oh
yeah you do victory dance nice thank you
that is what i forgot to do i forgot to
brendan is requesting that you juju on
that beat juju on that deal
i'm not down with
the hip lingo these days what is it juju
on that it's a popular song right now i
believe i think there's a dance story i
like what are they jujubes are they the
candies jujubes do you remember those
they used to have them at movie theaters
remember
brendan asks will watchdog's two-story
have a lot of action yeah absolutely
yeah there is there's a lot of action
here you can play it one of a few ways
actually whether you want to go all
stealthy or if you want to uh just guns
blazing yeah they have the skill tree so
you can kind of go more hacky or more uh
more
yeah yeah more action hero
so what are we trying to do here um
uh well i just said oh dude what if ever
there were a vehicle made for car
surfing
it would be the best oh the surfboard on
top
on top yeah you have to surf it it's got
a surfboard yeah you got a car first of
all can i
start dancing oh can i dance and car
serve at the same
time man this is the greatest thing this
is the greatest thing that's awesome
this is amazing
you have no vision i don't need that
vision
this is the definition of blind luck
you finally hit something all right that
was great oh but what i do see is a
great looking car right here all right
what do we have in our uh
our mission logs for this mission is it
this one
so uh the dedsec app the eyeball
how many missions did we accomplish
because i just we accomplished one i
have to like you stole the battery and
we got first one i have to let you know
that our pizza has arrived oh pizza has
arrived
i've laid out some fine pizza for y'all
oh my goodness can't wait till you see
it looks
delicious it is here but first red
sticks and pizza feast your eyes on this
beautiful box that's a good box so this
is the triple treat box and this is how
you win the special xbox one s and the
sweet controller
and the code for that is actually
inside we can't show you the code
because it's for us because we're going
to enter yeah
just so you know
they would steal your it's on the inside
front flap so if it's going to be in
here okay and so easy to find yes easy
to find but what you get inside this
triple treat box
three trays and you see it all on this
table right here so you get two
one topping medium sized pizzas
breadsticks
sauce and a hershey's extreme cookie
it's so delicious ultimate hershey's
chocolate chip cookie right there i just
i keep looking at the cookie like you
know dessert comes first right no you
can't eat dessert first you have to have
at least no i'm an adult
all right i'll tell you we completed one
mission go ahead and dig in to your
pizza yeah and then we're going to play
something uh we're going to get some
breakfast in the chat right let's talk
to the chat while we're enjoying this
pizza
let's say let's see who's ricky says
lasercorn sup
what up dude michelle says can you hack
people um in real life
can you hack people in real life will
the game mechanics be better than watch
dogs one yeah i think already the the
like everything mechanicalized movement
hack wise uh the things you can do it's
a lot easier it's uh it's streamlined
it's great
can you play without the online
multiplayer yeah that's how we're doing
it right now that's literally what we're
doing yeah that is what we're doing
right now in this game right now when we
get back to it but we're enjoying some
pizza can you hook a girl up with some
pizza yeah which one you want i would
like a slice of sausage please
thank you
so talk to us in the chat we're on
twitch and we're on youtube right now
can i get you a plate yes please oh hey
we have plates that's nice
i'm going to pass this to joven jovan do
you want to talk to these fine people
yeah i do yeah let's see who we got in
here so go to our twitch go to our
youtube send in your questions we're
eating this lovely triple treat box
right now yeah
all this delivered by pizza hut all
right we're gonna do a little real thank
you guys who we got here we got um
as i finished my pizza we got james
brown we got um
who's this this is hd games we got the
rock and roll gamer we got
who else literally
starts saying hi
um nelvin's
judy oh yeah fun fact about me i can
never read people's names well
um having some trouble there buddy uh
always we got uh
577. thanks for stopping by
um my god they answered your question
yeah we are here to answer your that's
what we did watch dogs and need some
pizza hut
uh gamespot audience guys if you're not
familiar with these lovely gentlemen
these are our special guests lasercorn
and jovenshire and they're here they're
having a pizza party with me on
watchdogs today um we got 50 wick 30 we
got death games music we got fallout kid
50 work 30 says how much does the box
cost
how much does this box cost well you
have to order it on the pizza hut app
so check it out download the pizza hut
app and
delivery and everything has to be
factored into it but my creed 65 says ha
jovan uh
i don't really understand the context of
your ha
um i think you're laughing along with me
or maybe it's typo maybe you meant to
say hi so what up hi
um
uh james brown says hi where are you all
from um the internet mostly we're from
the internet
uh stacy uh
what up
we've got uh
walls from the hoon
brendan hernandez
how long what's up michelle has
watchdogs 2 been in production uh
for a while
when did the first one come out two
years ago so i think it's like two years
in production for this code oh
oh can we show this to the people i
found the code but i'm not going to show
them the actual code
so if you're trying to win that xbox one
s and that's cool controller the code is
going to be here on your triple treat
box so it'll be right behind here i'm
keeping that for myself but that's where
you can find it
and the triple cheap box as we said
comes with two medium pizzas with one
topping each breadsticks and a cool
hershey's cookie right there that we're
going to dig into
cool just checking in with twitch chat
people too i heart wolves what's up they
want a laser stare hello
there it is
there you go just for you
have we gone too far says diablo
yeah
you can never go too far when it comes
to pizza and breadsticks and other
delicious things that's right
can never eat too much pizza and we
tried to do as many missions as we could
before the pizza showed up we got
dancing down yeah we got okay
okay yeah we had a car challenge right
through a glass window i think pizza hut
bested us they are
way faster than we are at playing
watchdogs too
how would you compare this game with gta
v oh good question
so
yeah so you play more of a good guy in
this game they both have great open
worlds
this game gives you a few more options
uh on the hacking and stuff side i think
but
in gta 5 uh there's a lot of great music
and you know the story is really good
and stuff i don't know i can they're
they're both really good games and
they're very different i think it'll be
easier to answer that question once we
are able to do more the uh multiplayer
in here yeah uh first of all the fact
that we don't have to wait a year for
the multiplayer in watch dogs too
already is a big win yeah but the gta 5
multiplayer is really fun
all right let's get back into watch dogs
cool yeah who wants to take the
controller next oh jovan's still eating
let me hop in there all right
go for it dude
oh the pizza box uh for the question
earlier is 19.99
19.99 that's a really good deal for this
triple treat box oh wow that's awesome
dude
me and all my buddies can eat this for
dinner
so there was a request earlier they want
us to go meet wrench one of the greatest
characters we want to meet ranch meet
wrench let's meet ron yeah let me let me
find the one
that's actually my favorite pizza
topping is meat lunch mmm good old meat
ranch you i can't go through you
wrench has a favorite cafe tracking the
mission
cool
also just so you guys know the triple
tree box is a limited time holiday offer
so
you have to do it now and that way you
can win one of these yeah it's uh
you they're giving away an xbox one and
uh xbox one s and one s and one of those
sweet controllers like every hour until
christmas december 24th yeah that's
awesome that's really rad a lot of hours
yeah
we we already have one of the treat
boxes so i feel like we're ahead of
everyone yeah get our entry in we did
all right are we gonna go see this meat
wrench yeah i know we're eating ranch i
just can't get over it sounds like a
meat ranch
it's the meat ranch mission fast travel
there oh yeah it's it's far away i'm
just gonna oh wait there's no fast
travel aha fast travel i actually uh got
a new toolbox recently and it was a
screwdriver a hammer and a meat wrench
it would just be useless
on whatever you were trying to do
there has to be a decent use for it okay
i'm breaking into the cookie
oh my god are you breaking into the
cookies
can i get some cookie please yes
absolutely
true
the cookie looks like pizza
i see it's not pizza cookie
whoa that's really good
all right
should i car serve to to wrench
i feel like
i feel like i'm eating the ultimate
hershey's
chocolate chip cookie
really good obviously not that good at
uh card serving
i'm really good at car surfing you just
get lucky
are cookies better when they're shaped
like pizza yes yeah shaping something
like a pizza automatically makes it
taste better it's more aerodynamic um
it ended poorly
it ended in sadness
but
that's a pretty good run yeah not dead
yet i'm alive i live through my car
surfing run and we're much closer to our
location why does this guy have a blue
this lady have a blue finger oh because
she has lots of money for me
471
that's like a lot of triple treat boxes
i can't do the math on the top of my eye
i don't know the math like there's a lot
of triple treat boxes
uh okay
did you just do math i tried very
impressive please nobody checked very
impressed with your math this is
wrench's favorite 210. oh they got
donuts i got donuts galore
place is called 10 doughnuts usually do
a dozen but whatever all right i'm gonna
talk to wrench everyone loves wrench he
has an awesome character he's very
popular here's my question is how does
he control that mask because the
different emotes change based on what
he's feeling neurons
probably always neurons
he's walking around who doesn't call it
someone in the chat check out joven
science
someone do the math someone on the chat
what exactly do you think about it how
many triple treat boxes there's gonna be
there's gonna be sparks in your brain
that uh give off the emotion
and uh so as long as it's
hooked up to the the temporal lobe
sparks in your brain give off emotion
science facts
science facts and jokes
to lasercorn on chat and twitch and on
youtube right now we're looking at both
so we're taking your questions send me
any of this delicious triple treatment
any of your science or mathematical
questions
i will be able to answer right here
right now what is hacking
what is happening what is hacking is is
when you uh find the life essence of a
uh technological item
and then you wind up manipulating the
essence of said item uh to do your will
which is that it's actually a mental
connection life essence not a thing yep
nope all of those things are things what
i've learned from the 90s is that you
can only hack if you're listening to the
chemical brothers ah yes yes that
once you get past the firewall you have
to say i'm in i'm in
like really intense the firewall
actually wall made a fire yes
it's very hard
a lot of burn sustained while hacking so
be careful that's why they dress like
that
okay
all right this has to be the most
fashion-forward game i've ever seen yeah
it's very fashionable
question how does the final game compare
to the open beta you two played
um oh hey thanks for watching that the
video before i actually feels like when
we played that that felt like it was a
done game and um we were a little
further then so we're we don't have as
much in the skill trees
as we did then but it feels just as good
like it i think was it was done yeah it
was done it was pretty much done um
they were uh i think they were just by
the time we played the beta they were
really just working the kinks out of the
kind of uh seamless multiplayer in a
world where every game gets delayed
about four or five months it was nice to
actually play a game in beta and then it
was ready to go
yeah
so yeah pretty good pretty good it was a
pretty good beta version we played nice
why'd you switch cars because that's the
mission so wrench wants me to take
someone for a drive
so i had to switch cars got it
stacy asks is the car surfing the same
as in saints row
no
better
what
which which saints road could you car
survey yeah because we played four and i
don't remember car surfing i remember
the rag-dolling missions and stuff i
don't remember really car surfing
inside definitely better than a gta 5
car surfing insightful reaper did the
math hopefully and said 23. 23.
that was definitely the number i said
that's what you said right you said 23.
yep can't rewind this video definitely
what i said
marcus very nice well you clearly know
your math hey miranda just manver says
hey jovan how are you
i'm doing pretty good today um i'm i got
some stuff done uh earlier in the day i
made it here i can hang out with you
guys any time i get to hang out with you
guys and chat and be able to kind of
break that fourth wall it's always a
good day kevin almost didn't make it
here i almost did it
um i don't want to give out any names
of airlines but uh here's a life lesson
that they never taught me in school
if uh if they say that your flight has
been delayed and you're still at home uh
still get there way beforehand because
at any given moment they can be like oh
guess what we're back on
so they're like okay we've delayed your
flight for two hours and then like i was
ready airport wasn't too far away and
then i'm looking at my phone and all of
a sudden it's like oh hey your flight
leaves in 20 minutes and i'm like i
talked to my lyft driver i'm like can
you get us there like now and uh he
drink he drove like a crazy man but he
got me there on time and i made it
i did make it
uh
sorry i was just i was just hacking cars
that's not that lame you're doing this
is own lane
i'm
that
uh but yeah that's good advice they
actually weirdly changed my flight
they delayed my flight by an hour coming
out here too and then they said nope uh
just kidding it's on time
yeah it sucks because you'll be at the
airport for a while but yeah life
lessons from juventus live lessons from
joven and lace or corn
i don't i i got distracted by our life
lessons and i forget what we're doing
i'm i'm literally at this point just
following an order you're driving
someone there's someone in the car with
you oh that's right yes that lady you
were the worst lyft driver
intel huh lyft drivers don't really i'm
exactly like a lyft driver i'm not
really listening to what you're saying
are you making awkward small talk yeah
just like asking if you like the music
that they're playing you have to say yes
yeah
it's like oh yeah do you like pig floyd
yeah sure yeah
i had am i supposed to say no yeah are
you gonna get mad at me
i had a lyft driver one time that i it
was 7 30 in the morning i was trying to
get to the airport and he's just
blasting heavy metal music wow and it's
like this 70 year old guy he's just
living his best life yeah well he's been
going for like 14 hours and he needs it
to get moving you're never too old to
keep it metal i guess i mean you're just
driving all day yeah you need to be
motivated
if you guys are just tuning in we're
playing watch dogs too it's launch day
you can play this on ps4 and xbox one
and you can play it on your very own new
xbox one s that you can win from pizza
hut they are doing a giveaway which is
tied to the triple treat box we just
ordered our own triple tree box let me
show you this thing one mogan
this is the delectable triple treat box
from pizza hut delivered by pizza hut
it's 19.99 it comes with two
medium pizzas with one topping each some
breadsticks and some delicious cookie
the ultimate hershey's cookie
and to win that
you have to enter the code that you get
on your triple treat box
and you can do that every hour until
december 24th because for the holiday
season pizza hut partnered with xbox to
give these away and you can find that
code on the inside flap and go to
pizzahut.com
xbox one for a chance to instantly win
that xbox one s
and every customer also instantly
receives 10 off an xbox game one lucky
customer will get the grand prize which
includes an xbox one console a custom
pizza hut controller which i have here a
samsung 4k su hd tv and an audio system
so that's pretty sweet
so definitely check that out that's a
good yeah it's a good deal stop
all this delivered by pizza hut thanks
guys
uh ladies when you were doing pretty
good with uh your missions there and i
don't want to take away from you too
much but i think
there's something i want to do again
i want to find one of those
missions with the uh very nice
very nice i want to see if i can launch
uh some cop cars on it
but let's do it in order to do that we
got to find one of those ram cars so uh
this is definitely
uh my van and i'm uh legally obtaining
my van good it's good all right now
let's see if we can find a ramp one
smart car car do it a home spokesperson
i believe in you oh right
no i bumped into him we're trading
insurance by trading insurance i mean
stealing your van
all right what was it was it oh that's
the button that's the one there you go
all right cool now all i need to do is
get myself some police attention it
should not be too difficult
uh do we have any more questions in the
chat
if you are on twitch or youtube we're
taking your questions or just general
things you want to talk about you could
talk about wrench all day
it was so sexy yeah i need this
this bus you know what i haven't seen
him do yet is hearts though like when he
i would love that like he was looking at
that girl's butt and then it was x's and
i'm like it should be hearts come on bus
come on come on bus
just
come on there you go we've got let's see
if i can
nope not you need to have somebody
thinks the driving here is better than
saints row i need a heck of a spot oh
wait here we go here we go
driving backwards
launch this is how you make truck babies
oh my god
all right that didn't work all right
we're gonna try this again sometimes you
almost made truck babies not quite when
they be bus babies
it's kind of like when it's it's the
same way of getting like a mule
uh when the um you know the biology of
it is is
how accurate is the game world to the
actual san francisco it's super accurate
actually as someone who's been in san
francisco for a while i'd say
very very accurate um
it's almost a scale oakland's very tiny
though they made oakland like super
small it's much smaller than it actually
is but you can drive all the way across
san francisco you can go across the bay
bridge you can go across the golden gate
bridge and go to marin county and go all
the way back around down to oakland so
it's very accurate
i was
kind of paving my path to work like i
saw like the ballpark and i was trying
to find the game spot office but it
wasn't there but the ubisoft office is
there of course
but yeah i think the only other game
that did it as well as this one was um
la noire which i did not enjoy uh as
much as i do this game but the map was
pretty spot-on
all right um we are now in a better part
of town where there's faster vehicles so
i'm gonna get in front of one of these
guys over here you know these are big
cars too come on oh wait oh oh look at
this little guy oh i'm sorry
sorry san francisco prius
all right so all the ubers i get are
priuses pretty
i don't know
all right so where's that card just
gonna wait for that card to come
where's he at where's he all right there
you go turn this way
turn this way you in my lane
and here we go
you're in my car now oh damn it i want
to okay i'm going to steal this car i'm
going to steal this car
yep you're mine all right gotcha
almost all right let me try this other
car this other car should be a little
bit easier
mine nope nope okay hold on hold on hold
on there we go
come come no no no what are you doing no
no just do it just be nice just go just
go in your home it's the most awkward
way to steal a car this is a really
awkward still in it yeah this is super
funny okay hold on we're just gonna turn
this way no no don't don't where are you
going where you gonna don't try to run
away from me
back up here come on nope nope nope
there we go oh damn it come on
stop it
come here there we go
oh
you failed me for the last time all
right question in the youtube chat jovan
and lasercorn what is what is your
favorite bands what are your favorite
bands or favorite music genres uh
what do i like a lot right now
um steely dan growing up honestly my
favorite band growing up was through
horizon yeah wow they they they were
um right now i'm listening to i don't
know what i think my favorite band
overall might be
like co-heating cambria or something
right now i'm listening to foxy shazam
what's that um
what general music is that they're kind
of like new queen
i guess yeah really i could be into that
yeah
uh
the actually the one thing they get uh
kind of the criticism they get is the
lead singers trying too hard to be
freddie mercury but um yeah but yeah
definitely check them out
what about you chastity what kind of
music do you like um i don't know i
listen to a lot of 90s
a lot of early 2000s i'm into all that
um i'm listening to a lot of carly rae
jepsen this year oh cool yeah did she
has she done more yeah she put out those
b-sides this year did you check those
out i have not really good really really
good uh bruno mars you know stuff i can
do thanks to is carly rae is that call
me maybe yeah that's right that's right
she is a gem
face
i don't think anyone can disagree with
that she is a gem she is truly a gem
let's see what else we've got here in
the chat no this one and go for it
oh my god all right i guess what is your
turn
it's like it's like
that poor guy you're just gonna leave
him on the side you should try and write
him question from optional zero what
would be more adorable a kitten in a
puppy costume or a puppy in a kitten
costume
wow that's debatable
i'm gonna say kitten in a puppy outfit
only because then i might believe that
that cat is a dog and like it more i'm
gonna say
get up get up puppy in a kitten outfit
because it would be like uh a kitten it
would look like a kitten but with the
disposition of a puppy which is much
more fun that is so nice kitty kitties
can be mean they can i knew a cat called
zap once is named after zach brannigan
what did he has a little kitty he
clogged my ankles he shredded my ankles
every time i came in uh this girl's dorm
room did i deserve it what no i didn't
do anything although
later after he first he did that first
but then later uh we would play this
game just a heads up i just i fixed that
card
yes
attaboy we would play a game called cat
in a bag where he would
that zap would run into a bag and then i
would shake it all up
and set it back down and he comes
shooting out and at first uh the girl
who on the cat is like don't do that
but then like the cat would always come
back and go in the bag and like if i
didn't shake it up zap would pick his
head up i'm like i'm gonna do the back
thing
so he obviously liked it
if you want to set up a mission
or if you could top that i don't know if
you can't
no what a question do you think aiden
pierce should play a bigger role in
watch dogs too
uh man i haven't got i haven't played a
mission where he plays any role right um
yes there's something
like being brutally honest a lot of
people didn't play watch dogs one or got
turned off from it so
i would say no because like it's kind of
its own standalone it's like like we
said earlier it's a way better game and
i think people should just be able to
access it without you know having to
know what's going on in the last game
yeah but everybody loves that trope of
storytelling where like the characters
cross over yeah it's like oh he's back
oh my god that's the guy from that other
thing like i recognize him he's back i
know him um
insightful reaper is requesting blow up
all the manholes please that was the
best part of the first one explode more
manholes please oh stand on it when you
do it though what find it
yeah
actually i'm gonna you know what i'm
gonna do is i'm gonna get in this climax
5000. i am the climax 5000.
no one's no one stops the climax 5000.
so i'm in this thing and then yeah
that's what it's called i didn't make
them that's awesome well well i added
the 5 000. you're right it just says
climax all right but let me get to a
safe heights
so we're going to raise the platform
it's hard to see but the platform's
coming up and then once i'm at a safe
height then i will explode the manhunt
very nice look how look how high
question for how long the stream will
last we have about 33 minutes left in
the stream so get your questions in i'm
here to give you advice on life
financial advice
science uh equity of poems
uh those are all things that i
understand all right i'm apparently too
high up to hack this manhole there you
are you can do it
you guys gotta find the right angle it's
all about damage oh
did we go up at all i don't know
something happened
you got to cover it covered you're
making a scene why am i going down i
think this thing's been destroyed oh i
gotta get out of here oh my god this
team is destroying the climax
that's a terrible idea chat why do we
listen to you
blow up the manhole well they didn't say
they didn't say stand on it hashtag
climax
hashtag
r.i.p climax five thousand rit the
climax 5000 will rise again
no one
we're also in the twitch chat i'll go
over to you i was paying attention to
youtube for a little while sorry guys
see that would kill me
see so if anything we've proven that
raising up the climax 5000 protects you
a little bit it destroys the climax uh
we got to find another one is there a
boat you can steal oh
yeah a boat let's go let's do that
that's something get out of the water
there's a lot of marinas we can steal a
boat oh look it's the seals
yeah sea lions can you have this as
airlines as a san francisco native have
you ever gone and watched the yes i have
whenever i have someone visiting town um
i only do the touristy stuff like once
in a long while but not usually but i
have seen the sea lions they're very
cute
over at pier 39.
they're nice have you ever tried this
steel wait oops i dropped mine that is i
don't know how
would you rather have no internet or
have no friends asks i heart wolves on
twitch oh man if you have internet you
always have friends
that you have no friends that's true
like oh man do you see that cool meme no
man i don't know what you're talking
about oh this guy's weird
and then boom friend's gone friendship i
didn't have the internet when i was a
little kid i didn't have friends then do
you see the coalition here
i would trade joven for three internets
right now oh so three whole internet
three whole internets you know i can't
even be mad at that there's
yes they're hiding their internets
from us
uh another question what's the origin of
the laser stare
do you know the answer is that why
you're laughing yeah
doesn't say you know the answer i don't
know
what what's your answer well i know my
answer i'm pretty sure was uh when we
first started doing some youtube stuff
he just we i think i may have been
talking and he didn't know what to do
and so he's like
i think
and i just saw on the little monitor
just like him giving me a death stare
like what oh oh he does that i think
even before that that it did happen
around that time and i was pioneering it
then but even before that um
so
man the the chat had us playing or we we
had a request to play some game
and or it was like beating the final
boss on on smash brothers on super hard
or something and it was really difficult
and so in order to in order to make it
so we didn't have to do that again i i
addressed the viewers directly and i
told them don't ever give us a boss this
heart again or i'll find you
so i needed to threaten viewers and i
just came up with that look and now they
love it yeah now i get requests for it
so it's not as threatening anymore
but the first time i did it people were
creeped out
they're like please don't do that and no
it's your thing yeah
so we did steal a boat uh we're looking
for sea lions yeah sea lions or a faster
boat
okay or a book we can hack
boat don't have inventions yeah it's
billy the boat
is going on adventures it's a whole side
dlc thing they're coming out with later
it's billy the boats adventures one more
question what are your favorite cartoons
to watch guys uh currently um
uh this is a an answer and a request at
the same time i need oh land boat
land boat
uh tiny tunes and batman the animated
series are two cartoons that still stand
up today but they are not available uh
in hd video and that i don't believe in
that we come on guys 21st century so
there's a call out
to us and tiny toons adventures just
some of the greatest cartoons luckily we
do have animaniacs yes we do yeah and uh
watch that uh go back and re-watch all
of that of maniacs
so good
i'm a big fan of adventure time oh it's
a great and gravity falls i've been
watching both of those everything's
awesome
yeah gravity falls is an amazing cartoon
yeah
it's about these kids that have to
investigate all this weird stuff that's
going on
in this in this weird small town nice
it's awesome
all right i also like rick and morty i
think yes good
selection morty is hilarious
cat schwifty says
get sweet uh what is that is that
something you can ride show me what is
that what is that what that thing is
that a tiny boat that's an orange boat
no
hold on is it a fast boat is it you
think it's faster than this boat i mean
i'll check it out if you want i'm
curious okay look at that that is that
is a very fast boat why do you think
that one's faster just because it has
orange on it uh aerodynamics orange is
more aerodynamic yeah
smart gamers asking gta 5 or watch dogs
i'm guessing this watch watch dogs 2 or
gta 5
i've had less
rage playing this game
um though i am still very new to this
game here's the thing uh at the end of
the day
gta 5 deserves so much credit because we
had we literally had a show for two
years plus when we just played that game
and we kept finding new things to do in
the game they are still releasing free
content for that game like it just it
deserves like a great place in in our
history of gaming
yeah i also have to go with gta 5 uh
it's just and you know what i should
that's really a question to ask after we
finish this game this game just came out
today uh so we don't really know how far
it will go uh but yeah gta 5 is just
phenomenal it's it's a rough game to
beat i don't think that's taking
anything away from this game it's just
gta 5 is great uh now this game has a
lot of potential uh in fact we're gonna
show off some of that potential right
now lasercorn i want you to uh with this
with this boat uh go in here don't don't
lose it completely wait oh boat garage
oh god no no no it was just the way in
that's a restricted area oh okay get the
cops called on oh they closed the boat
they closed the door on us okay that's
okay
keep calm oh i'll keep calm all right um
keep calm with this is
eliza hearts over on youtube is asking
that she's she's thinking of getting a
tattoo what should it be suggestions
something that you absolutely believe in
and that you will enjoy 20 years from
now
or
or gets uh dumbledore riding a
pterodactyl dumbledore riding a
pterodactyl that's for suggestion i'm
throwing it out there there it is
dumbledore riding a pterodactyl okay i
see your dumbledore and i'm gonna raise
you
um merlin from the disney sword on the
stone
riding oh wait why this guy's angry uh
and he is writing falcor there you go
from neverending story there you go
eliza
those are your two choices also i
suggest pizza
just like the delicious pizza that we're
eating right here yeah
watch dogs too
is a lot of fun it was delivered by
pizza hut today so we can play it also a
lot of delicious pizza that we're eating
right now
in the triple treat bugs
do you see a boat
nope no boats what do you want to do
with the boat so i want to uh find a
boat
get on said boat bring it to a place
where i can jump onto the boat again
and then um
and then commit some crimes and then
jump back on the boat and have the
police chase me okay um but currently i
think i i ca it's very dark here
so i gotta get out of the water
i found myself to be in somewhat of a
pickle oh man i'm gonna be all ninja i'm
just going to you see if i can say hi to
these guys first see if they have a boat
i went looking for a boat i have no
boats nothing about what you're doing
right now is ninja you're splashing
around in the water
directly by the enemies oh it's like
no see the guy oh uh take down
take down
oh
you did it nope one down then death oh
worst ninja ever oh no i'm going to give
you another chance though because i'm
still eating this pizza i need a boat
find me about to go home
let's see
we have twitch and youtube up right now
what's character customization like asks
the hoon uh you can't customize the
characters but there are uh so many
outfits you can wind up doing just so
i'm getting in fact
um
see if i can find myself a a
outfit store
um
an outfit stores they're called this is
the map right
nope
that's the map
nope which one is that i i want you to
guess
keep going this one nope not this one
top left the one that says noodle maps
oh
it's on needle all right uh looking at
this uh which one is a clothing shop
uh basically it looks like it's got some
sweet threads um yeah here can i just
find one for you yes please all right
are you the professional shopper on this
team he's the professional i don't shop
that much i just can actually see the
icons there we go oh
well he's had this shirt for like five
years
it's a good shirt is that a target shirt
right there like a year yeah i got it at
kohl's oh nice yeah there you go it
might also be for sale on target yeah
yeah they're up on their star wars
shirts
all right let's see what kind of man
that guy just bash that door wow kill
him yeah you can't let him no that was
rude
oh first wait wait it's not him it's
over to you just forget it go go get
some clothes
that's not even the right way he went
away that's the way i was going you said
it was the wrong way
ah you see that guy in the business suit
that's him this guy yeah all right first
of all you've done some bad things
oh you called them yeah i'm not gonna
i'm not gonna kill him there you go i'm
gonna
i'm gonna watch i'm watching him get
arrested yeah i'm gonna watch him burn
that's right i like this idea i'm gonna
be walking next to him like oh hey dude
what's up yeah oh it's okay you totally
bumped into me
um that will not come back to bite you
in the air
are you okay while the cops are coming
i'm distracted hit just hit l1 on her
what's her name
hey i need your info
hey whoo oh it's no sue jung woo is her
last name okay what's up
hey crazy stuff that's going on
look at the event with her oh yeah we're
just on a date casually watching this
guy get arrested yeah this is great
because you provided a way to stop her
and like something to talk about yeah
it's like oh it's crazy that business
guy's getting arrested oh i don't know
how that happens uh all right enough
small talk time to go
all right let's see what our clothing
options are
there's a request to get the stupidest
clothes possible
oh hey you
uh i would like to buy a guy looks
exactly like the guy that just dissed
you
yeah i guess go talk to him hey all
right sir i would like to buy five
clothes please five clothes can i do it
give me your best clothes how do i okay
how do i shop no i don't think you did
anything i know go to the back to the
changing area okay there you go
left there hit triangle on that yeah
there you go there you go here we go
customization time see what do we got oh
that's that's nice nah that's too plain
yeah
you gotta go
you gotta go fresh to death
let's try
see where is the ridiculous hat can i go
topless there's a bow tie
topless doesn't seem to be an option no
see now this is just one oh that's cool
i like that jacket yeah all right that
makes you stand out this is mine now
let's try what about wait what did it
equip
it looks like the color is different oh
wow see this place only has specific
types of clothes
do you want a better shop are you are
you dissing my choice of clothing
i just it's not as ridiculous as it
could be
you need a better get a cool hat oh what
three thousand dollars for a hat that's
expensive ridiculous tomatoes
whose account are we playing on we're
just spending all this money
it's fine don't worry about it just
don't save
safe do it
sorry spencer
whoops we have a spencer too
we spend all of his money as well
we have about 20 minutes left in this
stream i'm joined by my special guests
lasercorn and jovenshire we're playing
watch dogs 2 on launch day and this is
all delivered by pizza hut including the
lovely triple tree box that we've been
eating how's it
for you don't like that cookie i just
saw you take a nice big bite of that
cookie
i'm very happy with that i thought it
was a safe time you started talking i'm
glad i get my bite and get my bite in
yeah i'm uh
i'm switching up your outfit i don't
like what you picked oh no i'm getting
us better clothes all right was it not
bad enough for you is it is that out it
just it just works too well it just
wasn't it had no style
like i need something like
yeah i can't believe how
i am a teenager as well
what is this actually that's ugly
that's pretty
ugly that's super ugly all right let's
buy it thrift store retiree is the name
of the show all right and then bottoms
what goes well oh cargo oh that's a nice
combo what are they playing we're
playing watch dogs too
more votes for i second the stupidest
clothes ever suggestion we're trying
that's pretty bad
that's not a good look for this guy
and then some stupid glasses i guess
there's not a lot of choice in glasses
do you think there should be more things
to manipulate and control with the hacks
oh it's pretty it's pretty good a lot
didn't know that you can do no could
there always be more there could always
be more
you should be able to hack stuff that's
completely unhackable that hat that hat
the the green one no no no where'd it go
it looked like uh that thing no down
that one yeah that's pretty ugly yeah
all right so ladies and gentlemen uh
your challenge if you choose to accept
it which i'm gonna make you accept this
is some ugly stuff so i want you to do
what i try to do i want you to find a
boat
and bring the boat close to shore uh
commit some crimes
and then uh run away from the police on
said wait is this a ramp yeah so i found
a ramp yeah i was listening to you but i
have to i have to do a ramp thing
uh here's the thing is there's not a lot
of build up to the ramp because there's
that thing in my way do you have nitro
do i have nitro uh no i don't
right but how would that help oh because
i just start writing
yeah
uh well in that case back to the boat
finding business no i'm still gonna try
it okay it's just gonna go really bad
okay you're trying though uh more life
lessons with laser planes
uh so yeah you're gonna find a boat
you're gonna bring close to shore commit
some crimes get the police to chase you
and then ride off in the sunset in your
boat
is this thing down permanently oh no i
can ride it okay
so
i need to find a boat first
you're so close
yeah i'm not going to fast try it is
that a golden gate bridge
i believe so
san francisco native chastity is that
the golden gate bridge uh which bridge
let's see that one right there i think
that's the bay bridge the the one that's
the left of you okay the red one is also
which is which yeah so this one is
that's the bay bridge bay bridge and
then this that's the golden gate oh we
got to get to the golden gate bridge
you want to go there yeah it's going to
go there by boat it's pretty iconic oh
it's a lot easier to get there by boat
is it i would imagine you could just cut
through yeah it's like always having a
boat there's no lanes i'm on a boat
i'm on a boat take a good hard look
no
all right you're really good at finding
the slow spots this boat is not slow
first of all that other boat you told me
to get in wasn't even that fast
oh yeah i forgot for a second are you
going to try to get to the other bridge
i guess we're going to the golden gate
bridge
the mission he has assigned me is to get
to a bridge all right well you're really
close to the bay bridge yeah that's not
the golden gate
bridge he wants the golden gate that's
like really cheap how long does it take
for us to get there too long probably
that's why i said get a fast boat where
do you see a fastball i don't know just
keep going fine get to the bridge we'll
see if there's another boat along the
way oh you saw the boat you had me take
last time was not fast
it's just this is the same boat
it what yeah but the orange boat isn't
any faster why not there's one right
there is it a fast boat look it's not
even going as fast as me
that's the boat you had me steal and i
just passed it
we could take a sailboat is that fast i
want to run this guy over
oh that's a speed boat we should hijack
this boat that's what piracy
yar
tapping corn be here oh no
oh police boat hand open your hand over
your boat matey do you need to shoot
them oh yeah that's probably a good idea
that's what a pirate would do right yes
that is what a pirate what's that be
handing over your boat it's not as fast
so who cares
all right hang on and it's got to snipe
them out of there
you're oh uh yeah i missed him my eyes
are bad okay no i said oh that was a
police boat oh damn it oh no i should
not have gotten in the water that's okay
if i can make it to the speedboat we can
outrun them how do i go below the waves
oh god no oh god on the right side oh
god
i'm driving
yeah flow no pour
that police boat didn't even have lights
on it that was like a low-profile police
boat that is not my fault you had to get
the flight
i did have to get the best we were in
such you were the one complaining that
the boat was the boat was going at a
great safety that's me anyway did it
start us on the bridge
well this is the bay bridge run the
wrong bridge you're almost
dropped not that bridge though
if you really want to see this bridge i
can fast travel oh i'm going to do that
that's that's better there you go
less police activity uh but the original
uh plan is still in action yes steal a
boat steal boat commit crime and then
right off of the sunset right off into
the sun
yeah
all right yep let's look
at this what we're doing
oh wait a second we've been here
have we oh wait no me mario and so inky
were here i know you were here too this
is where we took the picture with the
the bridge in the background oh yeah
yeah
i took it to a picture of myself playing
ds
yeah yeah it's the golden gate bridge
totes accurate totes there it is can i
can i break through this no
why are they shooting at me what is
wrong with these people because you
broke the barrier okay i don't know this
might be there's bad people here yeah oh
wow did you just find yourself in a i
didn't even know what happened right
there that was not my fault
people just started cheating at me yep
sorry about that
one more request for one more laser
stare
there it is
there you go how do you do that without
having your eyes burned
i don't know my i can just naturally
keep my eyes open for long periods of
time look do it again
the camera's on you now
it just burns us
uh
that was fun all right to the boat
i'm gonna get shot again for no reason
probably
oh you guys got a very nice comment from
haley oh she said she loves you guys so
much you're truly great awesome amazing
and funny oh hey thank you and you've
helped me with a lot of things thank you
haley you're awesome
oh my god you landed that
i told steve but but now i'm stuck you
can't get out of that
yep well this was a cool bike you used
to get down the hill hang on no wait i
could get out can you i could do it i
believe believe in me
okay stop believing in me
why do you have to why do you believe me
so much believe me you just get my hopes
up we all believe in you it's like
people believe in me i believe in me and
failed
right there you go you got the speed
wrong you're going the wrong direction
you're going the wrong direction
get dammit
lasagna said what kind of pizza did you
guys get we got sausage pizza and
pepperoni pizza both equally delicious
and all delivered by pizza hood oh oh no
no no no no that was a far drop well i
guess we're closer to the water now
you're on the there's a boat there it is
maybe if you shoot at some
cars now maybe you can get the cops on
you why do you want to get the cops on
you you know what i'm gonna let you do
this i don't understand your plan yeah
plan what's your grand plan here my plan
is to
um
run away from the cops and get another
breadstick so it's just uh
there's i know there's no one here but
maybe if i shoot enough someone will
show up we've got 10 minutes left yeah
you better do something to make your
dreams come true you're on the clock on
the clock ten whole minutes where are we
at
i'm shooting the cops at
no
no okay just shooting the gun
in san francisco nobody cares dang it
all right
i'm gonna steal this boat i'm gonna move
to a more populated area
good plan good plan and
and get in there okay this is my boat i
will call you the uh see you later
all right two the city
i imagine it's on the other side of this
yeah right
you know backing out the spot
all right over here that is not towards
the city hangar right okay
i want you see all the lights well
there's that city i assume there's
another city the other direction too
um know any uh uh sea shanties
sea shanty
no
not off the top of my head me neither oh
oh how unfortunately yo ho yo
that's it no you can do like 10 seconds
but then you have to cut yourself off
yeah we did it fair use
all right so i see i'm getting close to
the city wow this boat's actually pretty
quick that's cool
the same boat i was using
this clearly is it okay while we're at
it
so what are we trying to do uh we're
gonna get some police attention and
we're gonna have a high-speed boat chase
yes
and then um obviously i will end up
victorious that's right
we now have eight minutes for the
high-speed boat chase to occur
can you shoot while driving a boat let's
find out
i'm not like that nope what if i get out
of the boat i see if i do this
hey
somebody called the cops on me
oh wait i think someone's calling the
cops on me it's about time thank you
all right let's get into uh
hang a lesson
kind of go towards short maybe people
will care more
easier for the cops to get to me um i've
had a great time hanging out with all
the fans here today this is fun
and now they're going to see me uh wait
wait no i'm in dead end
have you guys played the multiplayer
chief is asking if the multiplayer is
any good uh i haven't jumped into it yet
oh i have gotten to play it at a watch
dogs event
it's pretty fun so it's pretty like
seamless so if you roll up to a purple
icon you can jump in some other player's
game and try to hunt them down and stuff
fun yeah i enjoyed it sounds like a good
time and then there's a mode where you
like try and pack and and uh steal data
from another hacker in the game it's
pretty cool
pretty good still children what is your
plan i'm looking for cops it's very hard
for cops to like it's taking a while
to see that if i could just find someone
to um you know uh hack into their life
and make their life stop uh
make their lives hack them to death is
that what you're trying to do while
we're watching joven's mission i just
want to tell you one more time about
this really cool promotion that's going
on so you can win this really cool pizza
hut xbox controller with an xbox one s
also thanks to our friends from pizza
hut and the custom xbox controller here
can be yours you can win one of these
right now from pizza hut because for the
holiday season pizza hut partnered with
xbox to give away a newly released xbox
one s console and this custom controller
every hour until december 24th and you
can find the code on the triple treat
box i'm going to pull this up for you
again
so when you order one of these it's only
19.99 you can find a code on the inside
flap of the triple treat box and enter
at pizzahut.com xbox one for a chance to
instantly win an xbox one s also every
customer also instantly receives a 10
off xbox 10 off an xbox game and one
lucky customer will also win the grand
prize which includes an xbox one s
console the custom pizza controller
which i'm going to show you one more
time and a samsung 4k su hd tv and an
audio system so that's super sweet so go
ahead and enter by getting your triple
treat box we enjoyed ours very much
we got two medium pizzas with one
topping each some breadsticks and a
giant hershey's cookie looks like we've
uh attracted meanwhile
meanwhile back in the game
look the police are here yes the police
are here are we going to get our high
speed chase uh we we hacked into some
people okay um they are no longer
breathing hack those police to death uh
now i just have this hacked him to
pieces
he's just chasing me you can't catch me
all right let me see if i can do this
the boat's fast all right and go this
way
they regain control their vehicle
they're still after you joe
unfortunately
all right there you go oh yeah now
they've uh go find what did you say
billy the boat where's billy the boat
the boats adventures here i'll let me
see if i can uh come help you uh let me
uh are you going to try and find that
cop that you just sent into nowhere
i want to see
this boat over succeed where i failed
pirate that ship all right
what's that guy doing he's just like no
don't take much oh you get out of here
get out of here
you know i had to get rid of the cops oh
okay hey uh yeah you keep sailing behind
the wheel just hey what are you doing
just give something to him get rid of
that guy
okay i know
yeah i'm not gonna take over the ship
with sleight of hand
i'm dancing get him oh wait
i'm gonna you're out of botnet oh no you
had just enough all right hey just go
around to the side you got to get around
that wheel friend yeah okay i need this
boat i need this boat i need this boat
oh that's how you do it that is how you
probably
you didn't hijack that boat at all
all right it's okay it's gonna be okay
it's okay you might come off no yeah
question if you had your own boat what
would you call it laser corn
uh man i don't know the cu later is
pretty good the yeah that's good the
the cu r2 c2 oh we're calling it the r2c
i was going to say that we can get boats
together and then yours could be
alligator mine would be see you later
we'll ride off into the sunset together
that's really great yeah
i could totally see that happening yeah
so what are you going to try to do here
uh i don't know
three minutes left three minutes you'll
have to find something to do mm-hmm
are you beat up this guy in the goofy
outfit you got your uh let's see let me
let me let me see what his deal is he's
just doing his job he's applied for a
second mortgage he's an advertising
intern oh he's a crab person it's
unfortunate that he's about to get
arrested by that yeah arrest all crab
people
crap bad people are a threat to humanity
and so he must be arrested i just want
to see the cops come and
arrest this crowd
being a crab and trying to
trying to do people things i just a
heads up you are holding a giant gun oh
right standing next to the people that
the cop is going to try to there we go
oh you just tackled
the crabs someone's having seafood
tonight yeah
oh poor guy oh wow at least there's got
to be some cushion in that right yeah
the suit probably can you hack a cop
to get another cop to arrest oh wow
uh call the cops on a cop yeah i can try
you running no i could call a hit on him
but i don't have enough botnet
oh wait but i can steal some botnet from
this guy now we have button it yep oh
wait oh he just keeps getting tagged wow
this this is this is he's having some
dignity man i feel the need to help him
he's having a rough go of things i feel
like i have to help this crab out let's
pour innocent crap
oh that's gonna go boom isn't it uh well
i set it off but it didn't work
all right
i think we have to avenge this crab no
uh he looks dead he should probably
shock him back to life
i think we should avenge him avenge oh
for the crab people oh night night
in honor of all crab people uh taste him
taste him bro
taste that bro hang on
i'm just setting off
explosives okay let me get my stun gun
out
oh wait cop
yeah
yeah go to sleep get tased
i'm the number one stunner there we go
oh man
i'm tasing everything so many people
just going to we have one minute left in
the stream
taste free make it count taste everyone
is there how many people are getting in
a minute is there a forklift i'll see if
they i can find one oh god it's a dog
that's how you win the game watch the
dog i'll just follow him on his
adventure hack the dog
i don't believe i can follow the dog
home does he have a hackable dog collar
oh that would be bad oh did you just
uh that did you shot caller
i think all right
no this dog did it
so thank you guys so much for playing
watching
us thank you for having us here uh thank
you to pizza hut for the pizza thank you
so much
for the triple treat box thank you to
the gamespot audience for graciously uh
bringing us in and letting us be one of
you for the day yes that's so nice
that's awesome so this was watch dogs 2
brought to us by our friends at pizza
hut this all this delivered by pizza hut
and don't forget to enter to try to win
your xbox 1s and your pizza hut
controller yeah get that triple treat
box it's only 19.99 the code's in here
and for all things watchdogs 2 and pizza
stick with gamespot
thanks for watching
you